افادت السلطات الروسيه منذ قليل بمقتل
المراسل الحربي الموالي لروسيا مكسيم
فامين في تفجير استهدفه بمقهى في مدينه
السان بطرسبرج ونقلت وكاله التاسع الروسيه
عن السلطات ان العبوه التي انفجرت في
المقهى كانت مخبئه في تمثال تم تقديمه
للمراسل اثناء تكريم له وقالت السلطات
الروسيه ان 16 شخصا اصيبوا في هذا التفجير
معنى الان من دون يس مراسله الجزيره رانيا
الدريدي رانيا ماذا في تفاصيل هذا الحادث
وكيف تقراه السلطات الروسيه هناك
بدايه يعني حتى هذه اللحظه يعني لم نتلمس
اي تصريحات رسميه من قبل السلطات الروسيه
حتى هذه اللحظه ولكن لو تناولنا ما يتم
تداوله خاصه هنا في دنيس حيث نحن متواجدين
سواء من قبل العسكريين الذين نراهم او حتى
الصحفيين وحتى ما نقراه في المواقع
الصحفيه المختلفه والعسكريه فيما يتعلق
بهذا الحادث يعني يمكن القول ان هناك
اجماع ان ما جرى في مقهى اليوم ايمان هو
هي عمليه اغتيال متعمده بل واكثر من ذلك
ذهب الكثيرون
لتسميه ذلك بالعمل الارهابي وهناك يعني
تصريحات كثيره تقول ان يعني من نفذ هذه
العمليه يعني له صله بالسلطات الاوكرانيه
والاستخبارات الاوكرانيه اذا هناك تحميل
للجانب الاوكراني مسؤوليه هذه العمليه
يعني كل ذلك يعني مرتبط بدرجه الاولى
ايمان مع انشطه هذا الصحفي الم الحربي
الذي كثيرا ما عمل ولازال يعمل فيه منطقه
العمليه العسكريه في تلك المناطق التي
يعني تخضع لسيطره
القوات الروسيه والسلطات هنا في دانياسك
هو مراسل حرب لحرب لديه العديد من
المقالات واللقاءات الصحفيه هناك برنامج
يقدمه يوميا على موقعه في التليجرام حول
حيثيات وتطورات العمليه العسكريه على
الارض في اوكرانيا وعليه فانه هو انطلاقا
من انشطته
على الصعيد العسكري السياسي هنا بشكل عام
هناك العديد من يحمل بهذه اجل هذا السبب
السلطات الاوكرانيه والاستخبارات
الاوكرانيه مسؤوليه هذه الحادث والوقوف
ورائه حتى هذه اللحظه وفقا للمعطيات
الرسميه فضلا عن مقتل هذا الصحفي هناك 16
شخصا قد اصيب بجروح وفقا لمعطيات وزاره
الداخليه الروسيه الحاكم حاكم سانت تدرس
كان قد زار المكان واكد انه تم حاليا تمت
السيطره على الوضع وان انه يتم تقديم
المساعده الطبيه الضروريه لكل من يعني
تضرر جراء هذا الحادث
وسائل الاعلام وبكالات الانباء تحدثت عن
انه وفقا لي مصادر مطلعه فانه تم الحديث
عن انه تم اتخاذ اجراءات الامنيه الضروريه
خلال الامسيه التي تم تنظيمها في هذا
المقهى من قبل هذا الصحفي
التقى خلالها بجمله مع من الصحفيين
والنشطاء وان عمليه الاختياد على الرغم من
الاجراءات الامنيه التي تم اتخاذها على ما
يبدو كانت غير كافيه ايمان اذ وفقا لي
المعطيات الاوليه فان فتاه قامت بتقديم
هديه لهذه الصحفي وهي عباره عن تمثال تم
زرع قنبله في داخله وبالتالي تفجير هذا
الصحفي والمقهى رانيا الدريدي مراسله
الجزيره كنت معنا من دونياس شكرا لك